just before we get started i do want to
say that this video is brought to you by
beardblaze some of you might have heard
this before that i've got another
channel called business plays and that
actually led
the development of this very product
here
a fan of that channel sent me an email
was like simon i heard you make it a
joke about youtubers starting beauty
rages he said don't start a beauty range
but i can help you do some beer dolls
and i was like okay
beardblaze makes a full luscious beard a
reality solving all of life's problems
with fine facial hair not a guarantee
life's problems that is the bid will be
awesome what happened was the guy that i
teamed up with will he sent me a bunch
of different beard all samples i rubbed
them all into my beard like some kind of
crazy experimental lab rat and then i
chose the ones i liked we bottled them
up and
we made this product what i like about
this is other than the oils being
fantastic
of course and all natural all of that
good stuff is this we made a big bottle
because i've used beard oils before and
they always come in these tiny little
bottles and they're super expensive so
this is a big bottle and it's at a super
reasonable price you can find it at
beardblaze.com there's a whole range of
different oils that we
experimented with and tried out find a
link below and let's get into the video
imagine a substance so deadly that just
a couple of drops is enough to kill you
a substance that's colorless tasteless
and odorless capable of being mixed in
with water or sprinkled on food
without you even realizing now imagine
that this substance doesn't just end
your life
but it ends your life in the most nasty
way possible
blinding you racking your body with
painful spasms even as you
cough up vast quantities of blood sounds
like something from fiction
right a nightmarish weapon torn from the
pages of an
airport thriller yet this weapon is
frighteningly real
its name is sarin and it's one of the
most dangerous substances known to man
first discovered by chemists working in
nazi germany sarin was a quantum
leap in the evolution of chemical
weapons capable of killing a human in
under 10 minutes it's easy to make
easy to spread and easy to use for
causing carnage on an unprecedented
scale
a favorite of rogue governments and
terror groups alike this is the story of
sarin
the nazi's deadly nerve gas
[Music]
in the gigantic red book of things that
will glue in super horrible ways perhaps
the most
horrible chapter of all is the one
titled nerve agents
a class of chemical weapon nerve agents
block a specific enzyme in your body
one named cholinesteros but if that
sounds a little abstract just know that
the effects are anything but
cholinesterase's job
is to function as your body's off switch
when your nerve cells send a signal they
release acetylcholine flipping the on
switch to stimulate your muscles
take cholinesterase out and your body
gets stuck in on mode
the results are extremely not pretty
exposed to low concentrations of sarinyl
suffer
rapid breathing a racing heart and
blurred vision your skin will become
slick with sweat your pupils contract
the size of pinpricks you might begin
vomiting might experience a
sharp change in blood pressure if the
sarin touched exposed skin the muscle
beneath will twitch
uncontrollably the good news is that the
symptoms from a mild dose almost never
translate to death
the bad news is that a mild dose is as
little as one or two drops
and the difference between a mild dose
and a heavy dose of sarin is
like the difference between tripping
over and falling into the grand canyon
if exposed to several drops your muscles
will start to spasm uncontrollably
convulsions will grip you
sharp enough to make you collapse your
respiratory system will fail
suffocating you and in extreme cases
your lungs will start to produce fluids
pinkish foam will froth from your mouth
from here the next few minutes are
crucial nearly all sarin deaths occur
within 10 minutes
manage to hang on for 20 and there's a
significant chance you'll survive
yet even if you pull through you may
find yourself suffering
through decades of after effects
according to one 2010 study this could
include
anything from impaired vision to numb
limbs or constant dizziness
so nerve agents everybody not great
substances to [ __ ] around with but it's
not the deadliness of saturn or the way
that it kills you that makes it such a
tempting weapon
it's how hard it can be to detect in its
purified form sarin has no color no
odour
no taste it mixes well with water can
quickly evaporate from a liquid into a
vapor and spreads throughout an affected
area
with terrifying ease that means you can
get sarin poisoning by being exposed to
its liquid form or inhaling its vapor
form but also by having someone
contaminate your food or drink or even
by
just touching someone else's clothes yep
clothes in mass casualty sarin attacks
the
vapor clinging to victims clothing has
sometimes poisoned first responders
rushing to help them
despite all this horribleness though
there is one silver lining to this
massive cloud of death
sarin poisoning is treatable a deep
injection of atropine widely available
in most hospitals counteracts the nerve
agents
bringing your muscles back under control
so long as you're treated quickly the
odds are you'll survive with little
long-term damage
you know be on the ptsd but since this
is a biographic dangerous substances
video you can probably
guess that this minor upside is balanced
out
by a horrifying downside and that
downside is this
sarin may be treatable but it's also
scary easy to make
there are about 12 different recipes
some involving scheduled substances like
methylphosphenol dichloride
others using more common ingredients
like rubbing alcohol and sodium fluoride
the only catch
is that you'll need both a decent lab
and some serious chemistry skills to
ensure that you don't have any
accidents as one article we read
succinctly put it sarin is not hard to
make but it is hard to make without
killing yourself
this is why the crazed actresses and
jealous elvis impersonators from our
write-in video
don't get into the sarin game one wrong
step
and it's hello gruesome death still
saren is easy enough to manufacture that
it's proven tempting for scary
governments
starting with the scariest of them all
you guessed it it's time to talk about
the third reich
in 1936 33 year old gerhard schroeder
found himself working on a highly
sensitive project
a darkhead lad with a pale face and
thick glasses that he liked to take off
for photos
schroeder had been charged with ridding
nazi germany of one of its greatest
pests
weevils out on the third reich's farms
the bugs were causing havoc while
farmers could easily import pesticides
to kill them
berlin was worried that relying on other
countries exports might be a problem if
i don't know some sort of giant war
broke out so
ig farber had hired schrader to make a
good aryan pesticide
and now here the young chemist was
toiling away to create a chemical that
would super kill germany's weedles
instead he very nearly killed himself
while working with molecules combining
cyanide and phosphorus
schroeder accidentally exposed himself
to trace amounts within seconds he'd
developed a splitting headache began
struggling to breathe his pupils
constricted to the size of pinpricks his
skin became slick with sweat
it was the first time in human history a
person was poisoned with a nerve agent
then it certainly wasn't going to be the
last after three weeks of illness
schrader recovered enough to do more
research on his dangerous new substance
he found that it didn't just kill
weevils but any other animal that it
touched
in fact it was so toxic that his bosses
alerted the authorities
the nazis took one look at this new
ultra-deadly chemical and were like
sure we'll take that off your hands
named tabon from the german word for
taboo
the world's first nerve agent was simply
unlike anything ever seen before while
mustard gas for example might take hours
to kill
taben could kill in 20 minutes
remarkably
this would be just the beginning given a
fifty thousand mark reward for
discovering taben schroeder
was like well thanks for the cash here's
another super horrible substance
discovered in 1938 substance 146 was so
deadly it made even tabon poisoning look
like being nuzzled to death by the
andrak's puppy
when he presented it to the authorities
they were so impressed that they renamed
it for schrader and his team
taking the s from schroeder the a from
otto ambrose the
r from gerhard ritter and confusingly
the in from a guy called
wanda lind they christened it sarin it
was the dawning of a dark new age
the age of nerve gases and the third
reich would go
all in on producing them in a forest
outside the city of munster
a plum was set up for manufacturing
taben on an industrial scale by the time
world war ii broke out the reich had
munitions filled with it ready to go
as pan's attacks rolled across poland
senior commanders discussed using their
new weapons
colonel herm and oshner even advocated
dropping taben on britain declaring
there is no doubt that a city like
london would be plunged into a state of
unbearable turmoil that
would bring enormous pressure to bear on
the enemy government and he was probably
right
at that stage the allies didn't know
things like daben and sarin were even
possible dropping it on london
unannounced would have been like a
government today suddenly unveiling a
space laser luckily germany in 1939 were
so confident in victory that it didn't
need super weapons
blitzkrieg alone was enough but as the
war dragged on that calculation
was going to change before long the
reich's nerve agents are going to start
looking
pretty tempting
by the spring of 1943 nerve agents had
claimed their first victims but not on
the battlefield rather the dead were
forced laborers
dihernforth's factory where non-existent
safety measures meant occasional deadly
leaks but while the nazis still hadn't
deployed their new weapon in warfare
they were certainly preparing to do so
alongside the tavern plant a saren
factory was being built at falkenhagen
capable
of producing tens of thousands of tons
of the stuff there was even ongoing
research into creating still deadlier
nerve agents in 1943 nobel prize-winning
chemist richard kuhn began
studying dabun and sarin for germany it
was good who discovered the mechanism by
which nerve agents work
blocking the enzyme cholinesterase it
was also [ __ ] who discovered the third
nerve agent someone a chemical harder to
spread but deadlier than sarin
yet despite all of this research and
stockpiling hitler would never authorize
sarin's use in the war
figuring out why has become a minor
historical industry
all in itself one of the most popular
theories is that hitler had a personal
aversion to chemical weapons
we know he was gassed as a soldier in
world war one probably with mustard gas
and the experience may have made
him squeamish about later deploying
sarin of course this
runs smack into the issue that hitler
did authorize the use of poison gas in
places like auschwitz where
zyklon b was used to murder over a
million people
another theory holds that the fuhrer was
scared of what the retribution would be
for
germany using nerve agents while the
allies might not have sarin or sermon in
their toolbox they
did have other nasty stuff like anthrax
stuff they might have decided to deploy
after a nerve gas attack the last theory
holds that the nazis were simply
ill-informed in the chaos of war it
may have been impossible for hitler to
be certain that the allies hadn't
developed their own nerve agents
the fuhrer's hesitancy may have been due
to worrying that dropping sarin on
london would result in its british
equivalent being dropped on berlin
in fact the allies very nearly did get a
chance about their own nerve gases
in may of 1943 the tunisia campaign
ended with the allies taking a quarter
of a million prisoners
one of those prisoners was a german
chemist who spilled the beans about tab
and to his captors but because turban
was so deadly british intelligence
concluded that he was taking the piss
and ignored him still despite hitler's
reluctance to order their use
nerve agents would play a small and
pivotal role in the end of world war ii
in the spring of 1945 with the right
crumbling around them the lancies tried
to hide their chemical weapons destroy
their factories and execute prisoners
who'd worked in them
this led to giant vats of nerve agents
being shipped across war-torn germany
with predictable consequences in one
grizzly accident
allied planes bombed a train filled with
daben as it passed
a german village the resulting cloud of
gas killed four locals
in another near miss american soldiers
opened fire on a nazi bridge on the
danube only for
germans to immediately raise the white
flag when the confused americans asked
why they didn't put up a better fight
the boat's commander sheepishly
admitted that there was enough sarin on
board to kill them all behind the scenes
news of the nazi nerve agents has
a ground shaking effect as the soviets
americans british and french all
separately stumbled across evidence of
the super weapon
panic set in panic the other allies
might snatch this technology for
themselves
it was the beginning of a new arms race
one that would take place in the shadow
of the atomic race but would prove to be
no less dark
that was of course the race for a whole
new generation of chemical weapons
and so we get to the part of today's
video where morals just go out at the
window
the part where the allied powers offered
nazis new lives and immunity in exchange
for deadly technologies known as
operation paperclip in the united states
an operation matchbox in the uk
the project saw monsters like verna von
braun in whose v2 factories
thousands of forced laborers perished
spirited away
to become heroes among these highly
sought scientists were terence creators
gerhard schroeder for example evaded
punishment by turning over all of his
research when the allies arrested him
eventually died a free man in 1990.
worse still was the case of otto ambrose
the guy whose last name lent sarah in
its a letter ambrose was found guilty of
using slave labor at one of auschwitz's
subcamps and
sentenced to eight years in prison but
the americans arranged for his early
release and then took him stateside to
continue his work on nerve agents from a
certain perspective this pardoning of
nazi scientists sort of
makes sense the cold war was just a
couple of years away and
no one wanted to hand their military
rivals an advantage
still the speedy rehabilitation of war
criminals because they were useful
remains
hard to stomach as does the allies
post-war pursuit of nerve agents known
by the code name
gb sarin became uncle sam's favorite
great stockpiles of it were cooked up
stateside despite the potential for an
accident
an accident just like the one that
happened on november the 7th 1952
then day a jet armed with two 100-gallon
jumps of sarin blasted over dugway
proving ground in utah to trial
spraying sarin like pesticide instead a
malfunction sent the drums crashing to
earth still full of the deadly chemical
an inspection crew was dispatched to
survey the damage for some unknown
reason one 32 year old man didn't bother
putting on his gas mask
you could probably guess what happened
next 10 seconds after he reached the
impact site the man's body collapsed his
body gripped with convulsions
his reaction was so violent that even
administering an antidote didn't work it
was
only emergency evacuation to a military
hospital and being hooked up to an iron
lung that saved him at that time the
anonymous idiot had the distinction of
being the worst sarin casualty outside
of nazi germany sadly
he wouldn't hold on to that distinction
for very long over in britain the
british weapons research unit at porton
down and begun exposing volunteers to
sarin as early as summer of 1945. none
of the enlisted men taking part in the
trials were told that this was happening
they thought they were helping find a
cure for the common cold
the brits kept up this persistence even
as they began giving volunteers higher
and higher doses
the same year the u.s nearly lost a
manticeron poisoning the uk also messed
up giving test subject john kelly so
much nerve agent that he slipped into a
coma but the biggest scare came in 1953.
that year ronald madison volunteered for
port and down's trial so that he could
make some extra money to buy his girl an
engagement ring on may
6 200 milligrams of sarin were dripped
onto his uniform
it was enough to kill him madison died
that same morning his body broken by
convulsions foam spewing out of his
mouth in the aftermath the british
government covered up the incident and
continued the trials
saren's role in madison's death wouldn't
become public knowledge until 2004. but
that was just nerve agents all over
saren seems to have brought out the
worst in everyone who ever got a hold of
it no matter who they were
this was particularly bad when the
governments using it were already
criminal enterprises
augusto pinochet's resident mad
scientist yugencio barrios for example
helped the dictator carry out two
assassinations with the nerve gas yet
pinochet was far from the cruelest
tyrant to play around with sarin though
that honor
would instead fall to one of the
cruelest nastiest men of all time
saddam hussein
on march 16 1988 strange canisters began
to fall
on halabja dropped from the sky for two
days now the residents of this small
town in the iraqi mountains had
hidden as conventional bombs rained down
shattering windows driving people into
cellars
for those traumatized by the shelling
the canisters must have seemed like a
reprieve but that feeling could have
lasted for miss seconds
the canisters were about to unleash a
whole new level of hell
residents near the canisters lost their
sight suffered muscle spasms began to
choke on blood flecked foam
it was the beginning of the halabja
chemical attack to this day still the
deadliest massacre ever carried out with
sarin the road to halabja began
way back in september 1980 when the
iran-iraq war
blew up during the course of the
eight-year conflict saddam became
convinced that his nation's kurdish
minority were aiding the iranians in
1986 he placed his cousin al hassan
al-majid in charge of something known as
the anfal campaign it might better have
been called
the war of kurdish extermination ali
destroyed entire towns
carpet-bombed civilians had kurds
mass-executed
all told somewhere in the region of 180
000 died at his genocidal hand
but the worst atrocity of all the one
which would earn him his nickname of
chemical ally
took place on alabja that fateful spring
day
all through the day at night canisters
fell on the kurdish town delivering new
noxious substances
alongside sarin tab and mustard gas were
deployed as well as hydrogen cyanide a
lethal cocktail in the air killed
within minutes exterminating all that it
touched by the time chemical alley
halted the bombardment somewhere in the
region of 5 000 kurds had died
three-quarters of them women and
children the chemical master in halabja
photographed and
broadcast around the world by western
media outlets finally forced the
international community to act
in the aftermath of the iran-iraq war
steam began to build for an agreement to
eliminate the world stockpiles of nerve
agents known as the chemical weapons
convention it came into force in 1993
with 162 countries signed
up what followed was the mass
destruction of these weapons on a
colossal scale
sarin has a relatively short shelf life
and can be deactivated quite easily with
a powerful alkali
still some countries preferred to blow
up their saren-filled munitions in
a giant blast chamber or even just burn
them the iraqis now chastened by losing
the gulf war destroyed their remaining
sarin stockpiles by
taking them into the desert mixing them
with petrol and starting a gigantic fire
but even as governments across the world
were deciding that saren's day was over
there was one non-state group that was
enthusiastically researching it back in
1984 a blind tokyo fraudster
changed his name to shoko asahara and
founded a cult
embraced by japan's upper middle class
that cult had become filthy rich
eventually reaching a net worth
of a billion dollars unfortunately the
cult decided to invest the money in
fulfilling its central property
that deadly attack on japan would bring
about the apocalypse
the cult's name was olmshin rico and it
was destined to bring
sarin crashing back into the public
consciousness in the scariest possible
way
[Music]
just before 8am on march 20th 1995
kenichi hirose
was sat on the tokyo subway's marinochi
line nervously toying with an umbrella
at his feet set two plastic bags to
everyone else in the car they looked
harmless but hirose knew the truth
the bags were filled with liquid sarin
as the train entered the government
district it was his job to puncture them
with his umbrella
releasing a cloud of nerve gas at that
precise moment four other armed cultists
spread across the subway system was sat
exactly as he was
waiting for the moment for the signal
the signal to open their bags
and trigger the apocalypse the almsharin
program had begun two years earlier in
1993 with the purchase of a vast remote
ranch in
rural australia here the colts chemists
had been working on refining their own
nerve agent testing it on herds of sheep
far from prying eyes
once the recipe was perfected they'd
begun production in tokyo finally
nine months before kenichi hirose
boarded his subway train they'd moved on
to human trials
just before 11 pm on the 27th of june
a converted truck had driven into a
quiet residential neighborhood in the
small city of matsumoto
there a specially designed system had
quietly sprayed 12 liters of sarin out
into the hot summer night
a night when almost everyone's windows
were open to catch the breeze
as the sarin cloud unrolled across the
leaky suburb residents had
started foaming at the mouth had
suffered painful convulsions all the
awful symptoms we've
already heard so much about by the time
police arrived five people were dead and
over 500 were in need of medical
treatment
three more would later die of their
injuries as the first major terrorist
attack carried out with the wmd the
matsumoto incident could have spelled
the end for holm
but the police got caught up in a false
theory that one of the suburb's
residents
yoshiyuki kono whose wife was put in a
coma by the attack was the real
perpetrator
and the cult was never investigated
which is how kenichi rosie came to be
sat
on that rush hour train free to unleash
hell at 8 am all five alm cultists
punctured their bags and let the
disaster begin
it was the start of a day of terror one
which would kill twelve and sickened
six thousand as the clouds of saren
suffused train cars the authorities shut
down their affected lines trapping
commuters inside with the nerve gas
although the sarin the cult manufactured
was extremely impure it still left
nearly a thousand people with long-term
disabilities
ranging from chronic headaches to vision
problems to being bedridden
and wheelchair-bound in the years that
followed the attack two more victims
died of their injuries bringing the
total dead to 14.
thankfully this was the end of all just
days after the attack the cult was
dismantled its leadership arrested or
driven into hiding
shoko asahara kenichi hirose and the
other attackers were all executed in
2018.
they remained the only terrorists known
to have ever successfully used saren as
a weapon
sadly their executions didn't deter
other more powerful people from
continuing to use
nerve agents as you watch this war
continues to rage in syria a war in
which
saren has played a high profile and
horrific role
you may remember the gult massacre in
2013 in which the syrian regime gassed
its own civilians with sarin
killing hundreds what you might not know
is that this was just one of many sarin
attacks in the civil war
experts have found evidence of nerve
agents being used again and again
by bashar al-assad as with saddam in
1988 he's mostly been allowed to get
away with it
so that's the story of sarin to date a
story that is still being written on the
battlefields of syria one which sadly
shows no signs of ending it's certainly
not been a pretty tale even by the
standards of our
anthrax or bryce in videos but it has
been an
important one as we said earlier sarin
seems to have brought out the worst in
anyone who possesses it from murderous
dictators and doomsday cults to western
governments testing it on unsuspecting
volunteers in the zero-sum game of
international relations there are always
those who say it's best to possess
every advantage every weapon no matter
how gruesome it may be
history of saren stands as a stark
rebuke to this in this nasty gruesome
chemical we can
plainly see that there are some things
that should always be beyond the pale
some things that should be so taboo that
no one ever considers using them we can
only hope that one day with
saren at least this will become the case
so i do hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe
and as always thank you for watching
you